there is very little doubt that elon
musk loves his work with him being a
famously accomplished workaholic and all
elon has displayed time and time again
his confidence in the companies he's
founded and the employees he's hired to
help run them they did catapult him to
the position of the richest man in the
world after all i can't help but wonder
and i'm sure you can too how would it
feel to work for the elon musk driving
humanity forward at companies like tesla
or spacex fortunately we won't need to
wonder much longer not only are there
more than enough employees ready to
spill the deets about working for elon
i'm about to give you the inside scoop
on the daily life of elon musk's
employees before we can even talk about
what it's like working for the man we
have to appreciate the fact that elon
musk has a lot of employees how could he
not he's a renowned entrepreneur after
all he co-founded paypal tesla neuralink
spacex and the boring company elon is
without a doubt one of the techno kings
of the modern era and he's had that
crown for quite some time now in 1995
elon launched zip2 a startup that
delivered online newspapers maps and
business directories by 1999 zip2 was
purchased by compaq for a whopping 307
million dollars musk then launched an
online financial services firm x.com
which later became paypal and there's no
way you don't know what paypal is ebay
had the foresight to appreciate musk's
creation and bought it for 1.5 billion
dollars and this was back in 2002 musk
has a bit of foresight himself for a
while he was quite intrigued by the
potential of electric vehicles and in
2004 he made the incredibly wise
decision to become one of the key
backers of tesla you know tesla the
incredibly popular electric car company
tesla wasn't the most popular electric
car company back in the day all that
changed rather quickly when musk joined
the team now some of us can even recite
every single tesla model out there by
heart not to brag or anything elon's
drive for perfection has led to a very
unique and effective work culture for
his employees if he finds a tiny flaw in
what he creates he will have the entire
thing replaced regardless of the cost or
reduction in efficiency according to the
manufacturing engineers that work for
musk sometimes he can carry his desire
for perfection a little too far
inflating production costs a bit more
than you might expect however though the
quality of the products they produce is
a testament to musk's drive to make the
greatest product possible and you know
this drive for perfection trickles down
to all his employees you're not about to
show up to work and provide substandard
results commitment to providing their
consumers with the absolute finest
quality possible is part of the job
description when asked elon musk is more
than happy to share his thoughts on what
makes an effective workplace he once
talked about what it takes to attract
and retain the greatest staff well
according to elon the most important
thing is your incentive system the trick
is to reward innovation while penalizing
a lack of it when checking out an
applicant's resume his interest isn't in
what expensive ivy league school they
went to or how prestigious their degree
is instead musk looks for someone who
will add to the team dynamic through
creativity apparently musk searches for
four particular things when looking to
add someone to his team a strong work
ethic a flare for making things common
sense and trustworthiness without these
he's not interested in having you and
honestly who can blame him before you
submit that application to tesla you'd
probably like to know how exactly this
translates into his employer employee
relationship right well many former
employees would say the relationship can
be pretty rough at times elon works long
hours sometimes around the clock and
expects his workers to do the same he
famously slept on the floor of his tesla
gigafactory one year when there were
production issues with the model 3. musk
even claims that he doesn't have an
office desk and instead spends his time
floating about to whatever department
needs him so how do musk's employees
feel about this well a few of them have
talked about their time working for him
former spacex employee josh bain came
out to detail the working circumstances
he faced baim stated that the drive and
pressure of working in spacex led to the
creation of a popular employee motto
that floated around you are your own
slave driver he clarified that elon musk
never told them that they had to work 50
to 60 hours per week but when the boss
is doing it you can't help but feel like
you have to keep up baim further said
that he was given more responsibility
and freedom than at any other company he
had ever worked for which turned out to
be an invaluable experience for running
his own startup company after he left in
2019 a former salesperson who worked for
elon spoke about the difficulty in
working for a newer company one blip
along the production line and you've
just made a huge mistake the exact
opposite of what you want to be making
if there's anyone's word you should take
on this matter it's hans kaningsmans he
was spacex's former vice president he
was hired in 2002 during spacex's
inaugural year and was the seventh
person hired at the company and has
worked on numerous starlink launches
needless to say he knows a lot about the
company's inner workings as well as
musk's leadership style according to
koenigsmann musk has a very high bar for
each person who works for him a bar that
might be difficult to surmount being the
vice president koenigsmann also had to
deal with just how influential musk is
having the power to bend trends and
prices with just one tweet led to a
couple of funny situations like in 2020
when he tweeted tesla's stock price is
too high and tesla share prices fell
nearly 12
in the first half hour of the tweet that
must have been a really fun day at work
nonetheless koenigsmann says that he
loved the work that he did and that
leaving the company was bittersweet he
told business insider that he never went
to work and thought i don't want to do
that work and that he was always happy
to be there so what are musk's employees
expected to face well according to
former spacex employee jim cantrell musk
has a lot of ambition and is a unique
character he's very persuasive and
effective in getting people to see the
bigger picture and pushing his staff to
share his ambition for not only the
companies but the whole of humanity
expect some tall hurdles to surmount for
one musk apparently likes to set stretch
goals for his employees which are goals
that appear unattainable or even
impossible at first glance while this
may appear to be a trap at first it has
actually worked in some business circles
that's because employees are forced to
come up with innovative solutions toward
achieving those goals and even if they
don't they still wind up close in the
end way ahead of where they began also
if you have access to him feedback is
welcome as well musk has remarked that
as a leader he is not frightened of
feedback implying that he can be both
the receiver and the giver as long as
there is a strong feedback loop that's
become a part of his company culture
employees and bosses alike are
continuously commenting on their work
which musk considers to be a key to
success trust me musk is fully aware of
how demanding he can be he once famously
claimed on twitter that no one has
changed the world working 40 hours a
week and finally bring a big bag of
creativity if you can think outside the
box better than elon even better because
that's exactly what he expects from his
employees mitchell stevens a former
senior manufacturing engineer who worked
at tesla from 2010 to 2012 stated just
how often musk thought outside the box
recalling the first time he ever met
musk he asked mitchell and a group of
his co-workers what they saw when they
looked at a can of soda musk replied
that you could see a spaceship if you
multiply the size of the soda can a bit
of course working for elon musk has
brought a substantial bit of improvement
in innovation and no i'm not just
talking about inside his companies
although some of his staff have
commented on how he motivates them to do
better a former senior level employee
stated that after working for musk he
felt 10 times smarter than when he
initially joined
the kind of achievements his employees
routinely strive for are the little
things you know stuff that'll help
humanity continue to exist as a species
kind of like how humankind must evolve
into a multi-planet species in facing
that problem elon musk was concerned
with the high cost of rockets so he
founded space exploration technologies
spacex in 2002 it's an aerospace
manufacturer supplier of space
transportation services and
communications organization part of his
goals include cutting space
transportation costs and colonizing mars
spacex employees work hard every single
day to make that dream a reality thanks
to them spacex was the first private
company to successfully launch orbit and
recover a spacecraft the first private
company to send a spacecraft to the
international space station and the
first reuse of an orbital rocket there
was also the time spacex successfully
launched a tesla roadster on the debut
flight of the world's most powerful
operational rocket falcon heavy now that
definitely must have been a very fun day
at the office and that's just a fraction
of the things elon musk's employees are
expected to achieve under his guidance
they developed a satellite internet
constellation named starlink to provide
commercial internet service and by
january 2020 the starlink constellation
became the largest satellite
constellation ever launched with much
more to come suffice it to say that a
day at the office with elon musk at the
helm could either be a long day of work
or downright revolutionary brian bjeld
vice president of human resources put it
perfectly when he said i truly believe
musk embraces what leadership is and
part of being a leader is working for
your people we are not all here to serve
elon musk and his needs rather he's
there to serve ours it's a breath of
fresh air to have a leader who sincerely
cares it's not about the bottom line or
making a dollar to him it's about the
mission so what do you think it's like
working for elon musk and are you gonna
polish up that resume and finally apply
to work for him if you enjoyed this
video you should click on a video on the
screen it'll be pretty good too see you
there